A rational function is a function that's one polynomial divided by another
polynomial. Rational functions are like rational numbers, except, instead of an
integer divided by an integer, such as 3/4's, it's a polynomial divided by
another polynomial. We already saw a simple example earlier, in y equals 1 over
x. But they can get much more complicated, and therefore, much more
interesting. You might even have something like this. Y equals negative 3x
cubed plus 2x squared minus 7, all divided by X to the 4th minus X. Note that
actually all of the other choices that I gave you here, also technically are
rational functions. They just all have denominators of 1. Remember that
constants are polynomials, too. Most of the rational functions we'll see
though, look more like these 2.